OK, let's get in to our audience questions
for the week.
There's a lot you can tell.
We're getting close to this November election
and we are we're only about four months away
now because a lot of the questions coming
in from you guys are about the November election.
The first question is about polling, and it's
about specifically comparing polling right
now to polling in 2016.
The question is, David, how does Biden's lead
against Trump today differ from Hillary's
lead against Trump in 2016?
Or is this going to be a repeat of 2016 all
over again where Trump wins by a small margin
in a few states?
Excellent question.
The first answer is we really don't know until
people vote, which means every single one
of you should be imagining my vote, could
determine whether Trump wins my state or whether
Biden wins my state.
And you should go vote on that basis.
That's number one.
Now, let's look at the actual polls and look
at differences between Hillary's lead in 2016
and Trump's lead in 22 and Biden's lead in
2020.
Hillary's popular vote lead in 2016 at the
time of the election was smaller than Biden's
is today.
We've talked before about how it can happen
that you lose the popular vote by a lot and
win electorally.
That can happen.
You can draw these maps where I think I saw
one over the weekend where you could have
twenty two percent of the popular vote and
still win the Electoral College.
Just because you can make that scenario on
a map doesn't mean it's likely.
And so one of the big differences between
2016 and 2020 is that right now, Biden's popular
vote lead is bigger than Hillary's was on
Election Day.
That can change.
The second important difference between 2016
and 2020 is that when you look at some of
the states that are likely to be the key states,
the margin for Biden right now is far bigger.
Hillary in Wisconsin and Pennsylvania and
Michigan, for example, in 2016.
You look at Biden's Michigan numbers right
now.
They're insane.
So does that tell us they couldn't change
between now and November?
Of course, they could change what it tells
us as the polls would have to change far more
dramatically than we've typically seen them
change in the last four months.
And or the polls would need to be way more
wrong this year than they've been in years
past.
That's good for Joe Biden.
The other sort of number to point to is that
Joe Biden is over 50 percent and well over
50 percent nationally in a lot of polls.
Whereas at this point in 2016, Hillary Clinton
was hitting 50 in some polls.
And when she did, it was usually like 50,
maybe 51.
Joe Biden has regularly been hitting 50 percent
in polls.
And the reason that that's extra important
right now is two reasons.
One, if Biden's already at 50 in an important
state, for example, he doesn't need to worry
about the undecideds.
And the third parties.
I mean, yes, he still wants to try to get
them.
But the point is, he as long as he retains
the people he currently has, can win those
states, even if against an incumbent.
As you get closer and closer to Election Day,
more of the undecideds might break for the
incumbent.
In this case, Donald Trump.
So the 50 percent threshold is also important.
And then that's the last thing this incumbency
factor.
2016 was two challengers against each other
with an outgoing president.
Now, you could make the case with an outgoing
Democratic president, Barack Obama.
That is a help for the Democratic candidate,
Hillary Clinton.
OK, that's not a factor right now.
This is challenger versus incumbent.
Now, in many ways, the power of incumbency
does suggest the undecideds as we get closer
to November, maybe some third party people,
maybe some people who like Trump but aren't
necessarily thinking of voting might decide
to vote.
Usually incumbency helps you as you get closer
to Election Day.
The concerning number, if you're Trump, is
that as an incumbent in some polls, he's in
the mid to high 30s.
That's a very, very bad.
And that that as an incumbent is a greater
red flag than if this was challenger against
Challenger.
You look at Trump's high disapproval and you
sort of get an entire picture.
So in hearing me talk about all of this, what
should you take away from it?
Nothing.
Absolutely nothing you should be imagining.
I could turn my state from Trump to Biden
if.
I don't vote, that could be the vote that
gives my state to Trump if I do vote.
My vote could be the vote that gives it to
buy it now.
Rarely is it actually a one vote difference.
But the point is, a lot of us have these thoughts.
If all of us who have these thoughts decided
to stay home, Trump wins.
And that's the most important takeaway that
I can imagine.
Hopefully we will all make the right decisions
in November and hopefully November 4th will
be you know, it doesn't have to be the big
progressive victory that we would all like.
It would still be a major, major improvement
in the United States.
And I hope to be there with you when it happens.